relax
the cameras coming up Oh what's going on
greetings to mad flavors world this is
your co-host skinny finis and you know
me
big bad mad flavor welcome to the world
subscribe now cuz I got a bunch
of going on me the cat Clint
Eastwood behind me we're gonna start
rockin here
today's Tuesday we're gonna start
putting up monthly weekly videos just
like these where I explain what the
hell's going on I mean going to yoga me
hanging with the cats he's here because
I need sponsorship from Petco so if you
know anybody efecto take a look at that
beautiful smile right there
smile a smile anyway we're
here mad flavors world
Joey cocoa tears my man skinny if any
would come to you weekly you know I got
the blog on blogger I got the Facebook I
got the Twitter I'm here for you guys
but now we're gonna take it to a whole
new dimension you understand me so get
ready to rock again subscribe to Matt
flavors world
say goodbye buddy that's how we do with
you ain't around smile stay
black